the New Hampshire Republican Governor
kind enough to join us right now
Governor I'm sorry I mean that that
happened as we were waiting and blew out
of a break here but I'm wondering how
important a subject this will be if uh
it looks like we could be on the eve of
yet another government shutdown and
Washington's inability to get things
done what do you think
well that's just the fact that we're
talking about Washington what Washington
isn't doing as opposed to what they are
doing as a governor in the state I can
tell you we have federal employees we
have Federal programs those all are
really critical and they have to find a
way to do this there are Pathways to
getting this done this isn't some
impossible Rubik's Cube that can't be
figured out I appreciate the leadership
on the Senate side they're looking at
amendments that deal with the Border
issue to try to make sure that what can
what can happen the house at least bring
some of the folks over and find some
consensus but look the fact that you
have extremists you know on one side
kind of trying to hold the whole process
hostage over you know fiscal
responsibility and again I'm a fiscal
Hawk I'm the most fiscally responsible
Governor you're going to find but the
fact that they're doing that and
supporting Trump who isn't fiscally
responsible at all it's just politics
and folks just want to get stuff done so
there's a path there where they got they
got to find it all right now you
mentioned Donald Trump he has been among
those that Republicans should stand
their ground on this and if it means the
government is shut down so be it what do
you think of that
um look
I appreciate the fact that we they want
fiscal discipline but that comes in a
variety of different things it isn't
just about border security right I mean
border security is ultimately you know
very very critical in this and Biden has
blown it uh you know completely blown it
but at the end of the day it's it's got
to be about you know what are the
numbers what is going to stay open what
is it going to stay open where do they
want cuts to see where do they want more
efficiencies in the government we don't
American public doesn't see any of those
details they just see these headlines of
not getting stuff done and I think that
brings a sense of mistrust into the
system as a whole I mean the foundations
are there but there's a lot of mistrust
so show some transparency show where
those differences are don't just show
leadership coming out and saying sorry
we're still not there right the American
public smart they deserve more of the
details about why their programs are
going to get shut down and why the
government's going to come to a
screeching halt all right they're going
to need seven on that debate States
tonight one less participant than the
last go-round
um you last time we chatted Governor
were saying that sooner this field gets
widowed down
um the better somebody to take on Donald
Trump but he's running away with this
thing at least in the polls so what are
your thoughts now
well he's definitely not running away
with it not in New Hampshire not in Iowa
I mean it polls in New Hampshire have
them under 40 percent with a third of
his own supporters saying they would
consider somebody else and the field
does keep getting smaller that's a good
sign we had 14 candidates a couple
months ago we're down to seven just in
the second debate so the process is
working to winnow it down and as I've
always said one on one he loses it
doesn't mean he has to be one-on-one
with somebody uh in Iowa New Hampshire
but as you hit that slow super Tuesday
States that's important and on the
national polls be careful it's not about
National polls it's about the Electoral
College can he win Georgia can you win
Pennsylvania New Hampshire Arizona
Michigan and right now he cannot he'll
get blown away in almost all those
States
it might be an outlier but is Washington
Post you know slouches in this thing and
has Donald Trump up by 10 points that's
more than just the margin of it all
right
yeah look I've said it along that Donald
Trump can't win in in November of 2024
and Joe Biden's doing an incredible job
uh proving me wrong I mean Joe Biden is
falling down at every single step of the
way I think what that poll says more
than anything is Biden's more likely not
to be on the top of that ticket than
even Trump is because I think the
Democrat Party sees it they know the
realities as bad as Joe Biden is today
he's going to be even worse by by this
time next year when the conventions roll
around and I don't think the Democrat
party is going to have it so there's
going to be some other machination I
think other candidates trying to Vie for
that for that space on the ticket and
again if it's and if a new candidate
versus Trump again you know they're
going to go with it with the new boss so
I just want to win I'm a republican that
just wants to win and I don't want to
lose my governorships my congressional
seats he affects the ticket got it all
right well watch it closely Chris to
Newton New Hampshire Republican Governor
always good seeing you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else